going back to finding more about your
quote subject is there sometimes too
much to know ahead of time can you've
got all of the good stuff out in one
phone call and then once you meet with
them in person they're sort of flat yes
that happens you want to save it's
gentling that so much in the phone call
but when you arrive on location as your
crew is setting up or you're setting up
and you're starting to talk and maybe
they're starting to offer stuff you
don't want to be talked out you don't
want them to give up too much you know
see I've often said you know what let's
let's save it for the interview because
this is really good I don't want you to
feel like you're repeating yourself I
want you to be fresh with it and
spontaneous so yeah you don't you don't
want to you don't want to get you know
spoil it you don't want to get too much
out generally with the phone call it's
gonna be days before so that's not a
problem but when you arrive make sure
they're fresh and you know don't don't
have them waste any any any great
nuggets that you might regret not
getting and conversely what if they're
too on what if they're in actor pitch
mode and they're just too large for the
camera and they're regurgitating all of
their sort of press notes just tell them
that you're there you're just tell them
just to calm down most people you'll
find want to be directed in some way
because they're not professionally doing
they're not professional on-camera
documentary subjects you know so they
might not know they'll appreciate a
piece of constructive criticism that
want you to you know make them look good
they'll want you to bring them down so
they'll they'll they'll appreciate that
so you just very nicely say you know
what let's just have a conversation like
we did on the phone and like we did
before we'd roll the camera so that's
generally not an issue you're not going
to find too many people who are not
professional people you know being too
up I think they'll be generally it's the
other way around it's bringing them up
to a conversational level and learning
to speak you know in full sentences and
because generally if specially if you're
off camera you know you want somebody to
be able to repeat the question and the
answer and that takes a little time but
that's that's generally more of the
problem is bringing people up to the
level of what you wanted rather than
bringing in the DAO and if they're too
big if
again just be very honest with them and
say they're just react in a very nice
way just react the question in a way
that you'll get at what you need to get
at you kind of you know you you're not
going to know everything they're gonna
tell you but you're gonna know what they
might have told you before on the phone
so just remind them you know you told me
the other day that this happened and
that happened can you tell me that story
and they'll tell you you know so if they
don't want to they wouldn't be there if
they don't if they you know if they
don't want to be there so if by saying
yes they're generally going to you know
be very amenable to doing whatever you
know whatever you need to get the answer
out that that you that you that they
told you before you're not creating
anything you're not asking them to to
falsify anything you're just reminding
them that you've told me the other day
that this happened can you tell me that
story that's generally all you need to
do in terms of people that maybe are I
mean saying you know and hesitating do
you sometimes leave that in because
that's just a natural style for them or
people who are too fidgety
you know I the with fidgety I'll tell
them you're drifting or something but
with the arms and the hands if that's
how they talk they talk you'll clean
that up and editing you know you don't
want to you know you want to give them
so much you know the criticism that
they're gonna freeze up you know if
that's the way they talk that's the way
they talk and you'll you'll work with it
and again it might be part of the the
context of the answer you know searching
for the answer might be part of that
answer itself where they're hesitant or
they're duplicitous or whatever they
might be that maybe that's part of the
whole thing so you might want that but
if it's just an oh man and generally
when you go through your edit you know
you're gonna be cleaning up as you have
enough coverage you're going to be
cleaning a lot of that stuff up
you